in the fight against the pandemic the
fda authorized an optional second
booster shot against the coronavirus for
millions of americans but as ouija jang
reports there are questions about both
the effectiveness of the additional
shots
and who will pay for them
the fda authorized an optional second
booster of the pfizer or moderna vaccine
for americans age 50 or older
cdc director rochelle wolinski saying
it's especially important for those 65
and older and those 50 and older with
underlying medical conditions but there
are some experts who doubt the overall
effectiveness of a fourth dose dr celine
gander is an infectious disease
specialist i am very skeptical that
giving everybody over the age of 50 a
fourth dose will have a real impact in
the long term
on reducing severe disease
hospitalization and death
still with cases of the ba2 variant
rising and some european countries
seeing a surge in cases the fda has also
authorized an optional second booster
shot for immunocompromised people who
are 12 and older next week it will
consider whether the general population
should become eligible
if that happens the white house says it
doesn't have the resources to cover the
shots if it at some point it becomes
recommended that the full population
requires a fourth shot we're going to
need additional funding the federal
government has already run out of money
to pay for testing and treatment of
uninsured americans and next week we'll
stop reimbursing uninsured individuals
for the cost of coven 19 vaccinations
this really does beg the question where
should we focus our limited resources is
it on providing fourth doses or is it on
other measures for example making sure
we vaccinate people who may not have
even had a single dose yet
on capitol hill democrats are trying to
pass more covenanting funding after
republicans demanded it be cut out of a
larger spending bill senate majority
leader chuck schumer says he hopes to
reach an agreement very soon something
president biden will be pushing for when
he makes remarks about the status of the
pandemic this afternoon vlad
looking forward to that would you jang
at the white house for us wija thank you